i couldn't even graduate from the cub
scouts
i would remember the oath
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming queen
a girl who once got in a knock down drag
out fight with her dad over whether or
not
transition lenses are cool elise morales
and with us today we have guys this is
such an exciting episode
we have a comedian an actor a true star
of screens both
large and small but before all of that
he was a graduate of seward park high
school it's luis guzman
welcome i'm doing
so well seward park high school is that
in the city
that's on the lower east side it's on
it's on grand
street between uh essex
and ludlow amazing so do this is a
question
i've always had do you like do schools
in the city have
mascots did you have a mascot
i don't remember ever seen a mascot
if you would um if you could
retroactively give your high school a
mascot
what would it be
probably you have to be a cockroach
okay cool the steward high school
cockroaches amazing
there was a time that they looked like
there were more cockroaches
than students in the school right and
all but honestly
i also feel like a cockroach is a good
mascot because they're really hard
to kill like you can't defeat them
okay
okay so seward high school let's um
let's talk about it uh
what was were you like very involved
at your high school or was that like the
lowest thing on your to-do list no
um i was i was pretty much a rebel
um in high school uh
i was the guy that was always
questioning teachers and why are you
teaching me this and
this is not the proper history you know
so um in the beginning i got suspended
for being
uh this ordinance
so one day i was reading an article
because i read the newspaper every day
and back in those days there was all
these landmarks student
rights cases that were going to the
supreme court
and i found out that the american civil
liberties union
was representing these students so i was
getting suspended for telling teachers
this is not how i learned or this is not
the proper history
so i called up the american civil
liberties union really
and they showed up the lawyer showed up
the next day to my suspension hearing
and um basically he told the principal
that my
rights would be violated i have every
right to be outspoken
as long as i wasn't causing a
disturbance
so after that first hearing there were
like seven or eight more
over the next three years wow so
after this first one there were seven or
eight more for just like different
incidents yeah and was it
was it always lawyer
was it always just like trying to push
back against the
administration at your school
well you know it's a school that was at
the time
90 percent puerto rican mm-hmm and uh
when we were learning about history and
they spoke about puerto rico
in the world history book it was a
paragraph
yeah and it's like yo um there's more to
us
than what this paragraph is saying and
this paragraph
is not our version of our history
and so on guzman you're going to the
dean's office
i go yeah they were expecting me today
actually
i actually have a standing appointment
with the dean's office okay
yeah so um i would i would i would
i would call out i would call out the
administration for things like that
because
you know it was like um it was bad
enough that we didn't have
uh teachers like
our beautifulness and our brownness and
all that stuff
you know of course was this like ability
to push back and this kind of
like understanding that what you were
being taught wasn't right is that
something
that is just innate to you did that come
from home
um that came a little bit for me
um and also it came i joined this
this group in high school it was called
a speeder
okay and i speed up provided youth
leadership program
for young people so
i was i was in their leadership program
and it it showed me
uh the ability to question authority
you know and how young like how young
were you when you joined that group
i might have been maybe 15 16 years old
okay and was that something that a
teacher like saw you
and was like you know what you need to
be a leader or did were you seeking that
kind of thing
here's the funny thing what happened
there was this girl her name was
uh abuela and i had a rush on her
she was a girl from the neighborhood and
uh i'm never gonna lie i was hitting on
her and
trying to get you know want to go out
with me and so
she called me a sexist chauvinist
and i didn't know what that meant
like i'm sorry and she said you know you
need to get your act together you know
listen i'm part of this group
and it's called that speed up maybe you
come down and you learn a few things
and i go yeah okay and the only reason i
joined is because
i figured she would be there you know
what i mean yeah
but um it kind of paved the way
for me to become uh
a student leader um to be outspoken
question authority to get my facts
in the order uh i learned a lot from my
speeder
yeah that's i'm that's really awesome
and it's
it's a very like it's a very sweet
teenage story too like i do wonder how
many uh
young boys got radicalized because a
girl was like you need to get your act
together and learn something yeah
yeah and like and like i i thought it
was important
i thought it was important because you
know you're
a guy and you know you know back then
you're just going to hit on a girl and
but you never you never expect a
young young woman of your age to say oh
you got to get your act together man
you got to find out a little bit about
his history and who you are where you
came from
and about this situation that you found
yourself in
and so i mean um i
i was very grateful to awinda
for like shaking that up in me and
sending me
in the right direction did you guys ever
go out
did it work um it didn't work but we did
go out a few times
okay i think we got we made out once
you know i'd say that's a huge success
yeah yeah so yeah believe me i i i was
like
over the moon and then i found out she
was going out
later on with one of my boys and i was
like oh man
oh man well at least at least i got this
group out of it
yeah i got i got it out of my system
and uh i was really happy about that did
you
date around a lot in high school how was
your game with the ladies
um i had a pretty good game because let
me tell you something man
back in the day you know there were like
a lot of house parties
mm-hmm and i love to dance man i used to
go to house parties i'm not kidding you
all the guys be like holding up the
walls and that'd be like in the middle
of the dance floor
that thing with four or five girls at
the same time
you know um so i mean
i just love to party man yeah see that's
a tactic a lot of
young men don't realize is that like if
you're the one who's dancing
you're gonna be dancing with all the
girls oh yeah man
all the time yeah fine so
you know i had i had my uh my string of
flings
and uh but you know like my my purpose
was always just
i just want to go out and have a good
time um
and and that was my thing man like i
said i saw
i saw a girl that's on the floor alone
it's like yo i'm stepping up
yeah you're not gonna just let her stand
out there
but there are a lot of there are a lot
of teenage boys who do and that's
i'll be looking at my and my guy just
said yo bro
are you standing going to dance
[Music]
well yeah that's the most fun person
that you can be
that's it that's it who wants to be at a
party and just be
not partying yeah um so here's the thing
like like big time big difference
a west coast party like a la party it's
a very dull
kind of party it's not a new york party
because if you go oh so what's your next
project
oh what you working on next and it's
like dude
everybody didn't come here and talk
about business i came in here to boogie
to leave it on the dance floor and sweat
it off you know
yeah you go to new york you hitting that
dance floor for like three or four hours
one hundred percent wrench and sweat
yeah and you can't even hear someone ask
you about work like someone asks you
about work and you could just be like
what and like dance away
no kidding no kidding i'm like what
about work okay here we go
oops sorry
so who was your like crew
in high school were these other people
from aspira
or was it like boys from your
neighborhood who were like the best
friends
oh man well
i got i got to say for a while it was my
boy
andy my boy papa and my boy ray
that we were that was like one of my
first crews in high school
and those three guys were like the papi
chulos of the school
[Laughter]
yes i would like i would like the little
ugly duckling little brother
but they would like hang out and stuff
you know
but you know i learned a lot from them
they were really cool guys you know um
and uh and then after that i moved on to
to people like my boy um eddie perez and
diego ortiz because i met them when i
did my the school play
okay okay so i i did i did
the school play my senior year was a
play called bye bye birdie
oh i know bye bye birdie
yeah we did bye bye birdie in my middle
school and i was in the chorus and i was
very upset that i didn't get a bigger
part
oh okay we can we can always go back to
that school with uncle blue
and we can yeah we can we
we can go back to rachel carson middle
school and tell them what's up
we could we could like you know we need
a redo
we need to do because first of all
you know what i'm actually not going to
get into it because i'm going to get
upset but
i should have been rose in the play and
that's all we're going to say
i played mr mcafee by the way okay
is that um her father
yes yes yes that who goes on ed sullivan
exactly so what if
had you been doing plays before no
no what happened was that mr egghouse
the gym teacher was directing the play
so i walked in um i i happened to be
walking past the
school auditorium and i see him and then
i walked in so what are you doing
he said i'm auditioning people for the
school play and i go you can't even run
a gym class
you're gonna direct a play how did you
get the gig
as the director of the board right
that's what i said so i
i took the i took he took a script and
he threw it at me
and said well let's see what you can do
and it was like oh
dude man i got to check on the challenge
and that's how i ended up with the role
so you had never done a play before you
get in this play
listen listen i couldn't even graduate
from the cub scouts
i don't remember the oath okay
why am i being asked to sing to dance
to do lines and act that was a lot
that is a lot and were you
like immediate like immediately did it
click for you or were you
nervous wreck
the only thing that kept me going was
all the other nervous wrecks that i was
working with
mm-hmm you know so it's nice to see
that you're not alone you know yeah
so once i got past my first line i was
okay like my first line
we only performed it i think four times
two weekends
that's what we that's what you usually
do i feel like yeah
and so once i got my first line out it
was like
let's go and did you
like did you connect with acting
at that point was there a piece of you
that was like oh
maybe i'll be an actor or was that still
like way down
not at all man um uh
um you know acting
came later um after i left
high school i went to city college
studied political science
mm-hmm i'm supposed to become a lawyer
you know um
but uh i go ahead i was just gonna say
was that like the influence of
us and the work that you had been doing
there were you like i'm gonna be a civil
rights
guy i didn't know what i wanted to do
when i hit college
so they they took me into political
science you know
like you know reading greek mythology
and
and all this different type of stuff and
debating and
but um but uh uh um
i left college after two years because i
at the time i felt i had i had a bigger
purpose
my biggest my bigger purpose and a lot
of this did have to do with us peter
but also with my friend eddie and diego
who i met
when i did bye bye birdie uh they
brought me into this group
in the lower side called teatro
ambulante
okay and it was like a local
neighborhood theater group
and i just really was looking for a
place to hang out
you know yeah and so uh we did a few
plays and stuff like that
but even in doing that it would it
really wasn't that i was
pursuing the acting career because i i'm
not
i wasn't sure what i wanted to do i was
more like a
community i i became a community
activist
you know and i was hanging out with
poets and musicians and
painters and neighborhood activists and
i got to meet people like alan ginsberg
and and um you know how about people
like miguel pinero
mm-hmm
oh that's amazing i got to uh
i got to be mentored a little bit by
buck mitch mr fuller
you know um yeah i had a lot of
great influences you know chino garcia
carmen lopez
and around how old were you as you're
like you know
meeting these people and wheeling and
dealing
um at this point i'm like
17 18 years old
and do you feel
are you kind of like faking it till you
make it at this point or
what is your confidence level because
this feels like something that you would
have to be really self-assured to be
doing
not faking it because the reality was
that you know
you had the hospital was real
you know um sometimes you have to chip
in
a dollar with somebody just to get a
sandwich and share that
um um
again i i was i was focused on
an activism because uh you know anything
about the low east side
you know back in the late 70s early 80s
it looked like a bomb hit that
neighborhood
you know we were dealing with like a lot
of heroin
dealing with a lot of abandoned burnt
out buildings
abandoned cars uh we were dealing with
a racist school system race to school
board
that did not really understand
uh the population of the latino
population that was the majority
at that time and so um
you know there was like a lot of things
that would happen during from time to
time
somebody would write a play and i would
get a phone call
would you do these seven eight different
roles and i go yeah yeah sure
you know so we were doing like street
theater that street
you know so again i was just doing it
for fun
you know i never went to sleep thinking
i'm gonna become this actor
stuff like that that happened to like
years later
so what happened was miguel pinero
who was one of the founding members of
the new york and poets cafe
he had written a play at the time called
short eyes
okay it was playing at the vivian
beaumont theater
lincoln center and it won a lot of
awards so they made a movie into it
and so we got hired he because we knew
mikey from the block from the
neighborhood
so a whole bunch of us ended up being
background players
in a movie and i was 20 years old and
uh making 65 a day i was making more
than my dad made in a week
you know so yeah i did that
i did that did that movie got the
experience of it
and i just went back to work in the
neighborhood you know
so what was your like what was your
parents relationship with what you were
doing were they like
yeah did they understand it did they
understand the acting portion of it
um you mean career-wise
yeah like did they yeah did they
understand when you're coming home being
like i'm acting and i'm a community
organizer
were they like what is that they thought
i was crazy
they thought i should have gone to
college uh become an accountant
living long island have a two-car garage
have a wife and two kids
and like that wasn't me man i was like i
was like i was like uh
i was like a hippie man you know i was
like i was like yeah man i was like into
communal living you know um
um i was creating my own path you know
and my parents they didn't agree with me
but you know
um i didn't live i didn't live there
anymore
you know i moved out pretty pretty young
you know
yeah how old were you when you moved out
and where did you move
to uh i moved out right after i got out
of high school
and i moved to a loft and i lived in a i
lived with like 700 people
and my job was to cook twice a week
to in order to live there so it was like
a real
like a co-op scenario yeah man yeah no
it was great it was great you know
we actually have a photo i think that we
can pull up of you that demonstrates
your uh your hippie weighs this there
you go
how old are you in this photo you are
the most this is the most joyful high
school photo i've ever seen
i gotta say in that picture i was maybe
i don't know 17 18.
and was this a yearbook photo no that's
not a yearbook photo that's from a
[ __ ]
woof got those photos
i think that's that's one of them and
i love that picture because to me that
picture
exemplifies you know man that
that twinkle i got in my eyes yeah
that expression i call that life is
beautiful man because
it really is a joyful photo and i also
have to ask like
your teeth are straight did you have
braces what's going on
i never had braces wow that's natural
yeah yeah but um and all that hair is
natural that's not a wig
you know yeah man
so would you say that this was like your
classic
look just like big hair tea big smile
walking around the neighborhood all the
time all the time
and what were like like pop culture wise
what were you really into did you like
music wise
or if were there any tv shows movies
that you were really into at this time
pop culture man you know pop culture
i was i was definitely into the music
you know i was into like the
neighborhood jam session that
you know hook up hook up your turntable
to uh
the the street pole and have a jam
session
you know people like the early break
dancers you know
i'm hanging out at the original new york
poetry cafe
and listening to some amazing poetry
back then um you know
hanging out with musicians and you know
doing concerts and helping to set
up equipment you know and uh definitely
i got my satsang groove on
you know um yeah
um tv not really because we was always
hanging out on the street
we was always doing something yeah i
mean
you know i watched tv once in a while
but our thing
was back in those days going to like the
zigfield theater
and seeing like close encounters of the
third
kind or or e.t but i remember close
encounters
of the third kind because we were
we were like we were we were like
tripping
on mushrooms that's an amazing movie to
trip to
yeah and it was it was so brilliant
my buddy had the best mushrooms in the
world and man
you if those people watching that and
though in dolby sound
we're watching it inside quadruple dopey
stuff
you know if those people think those
colors were fascinating
they were quadruple as more fascinating
to
us imax before imax like you didn't even
need
you didn't need the 3d glasses none of
that before the 3d glasses
and imax um
that's amazing do you remember uh any
like
celebrity crushes you had at that time
like if you had a poster
man i had a crush on what was up
i had a crush on racquel welch
and who did it yeah that's a good one
i had a crush on uh co welch and i also
had a crush
on edie's choco
i'm gonna google her oh yeah so she's a
singer
well she's a dancer sing a dancer
she's beautiful okay thank you very much
she's a major babe yeah baby
oh and pulled up right on here
is playboy cool
she's a playboy i guess so you must have
missed it
yeah i'm so busy i was so busy
you really blew it on that one man
and uh yeah man so it was it was raquel
welch and eddie chuckle
those are really good ones um well
that's okay
let's pull up actually you have a second
photo here that i would love
to take a look at whoa
look at that yeah so this this photo has
like protest
it looks like you're at a protest or
something
yeah we are at a protest definitely
so do you remember when this photo was
taken what you were protesting
uh we were probably uh protesting uh
our housing rights
you know yeah and i was about to drop
that person
with a bruce lee dropkick
i was like it looks like you're stealing
the mic or maybe
attacking no actually i was giving them
the mic
okay great i'm not attacking
hey you never know but i think in that
picture i must have been i don't know 22
years old
and so would you like organize protests
and events like this or just attend them
uh both cool
so this looks like a how this was a
housing rights protest
how early were you starting to go to
protests and stuff like that when i was
like
uh 15 16 years old and were they
usually around housing rights or do you
remember what your first ones were
[Music]
a lot of them did have to deal with
housing rights some of them
that with the united farm workers and
the grape boycott
okay some of them were um demonstrating
against
uh um the selling of of drugs
in the neighborhood you know i mean we
all every time we all
went to a demonstration we all went with
a purpose
you know yeah something against drugs
farm workers better education women's
rights
you know things like that and so how did
you
as like you're a young guy you like to
party you like to go out but there's
also
this like real harder drug element
that's coming into your neighborhood
you're seeing
issues with that how did you like
balance
those two things
what two things like the between like
one
like i guess how did you keep yourself
out of getting involved with the drugs
while also being like a guy who wants to
party and have fun and all that stuff
well i i think i didn't get into drug
dealing
because i had a conscience yeah
um and uh i just
you visually see what happens to people
by people that grown up together and
gone to each other's communions and
birthday parties
and they grow up and they become drug
dealers and then they end up killing
each other because they end up getting
greedy or end up getting busted
and going in for 10 15 20 years
and then at the end of the day having
nothing to show for it
but also they were dealing death you
know they were dealing death
and it was killing our own people and
like how can you have a conscience to do
that type of stuff
you know so my conscience always told me
look you know what
i'm not gonna lie man i you know i smoke
my weed
you know i did i did i did i did
cocaine back in the day you know i did
mushrooms you know because yeah
it's the environment that you grow up in
it is what it is and i did what i did
but um my heart was just never into
becoming a drug dealing because like i
say you know i i never knew
a drug dealer that retired with a
pension
yeah that's uh that's definitely true do
you
feel like over the time that
you were like you know you're entering
high school around 15
you get out around 18 that over that
time
you saw the drug problem escalate or the
violence and all that escalate
oh yeah absolutely because i mean that
it was that error
mm-hmm the way the way that you you want
to control people
you flood the neighborhood with drugs
yeah and then when you flood the
neighborhood with drugs
then they fight among the cells of who's
going to be the dealer
and who's going to be the hey honcho and
so what you
do what you're actually doing is you
eliminating the leadership because the
leadership
has become drug dealers and it's easy
money
but at the end of the day like i said
they have they had to deal
with their own consequences and that was
like going to jail
or or going eight feet under you know
um and and like i said i just i just
didn't gravitate to that stuff you know
that well that's really interesting i
mean as a when i was younger
like when i was 15 or so i started going
to my first protest but those were all
the big issue was the iraq war so we
were just all
i mean i was from the dc area so i was
always going
to protest for that
and i think that part of the reason i
became a politically active or like
thoughtful
person is just because a lot of my peers
were did you feel like you had a lot of
peers who were also like
on that consciousness level i mean i i i
think um for the most part yes
you know but it was for me it was like
the older guard
mm-hmm well the people that were five
ten years older than me
those were those were my teachers those
were
my influences you know um
um i put it to you this way when i was
20 years old
i got a scholarship to go
study at the institute for cultural
affairs in chicago
it was a two-month course where i did
three years of college
in two months wow
it was it was the most intense thing i
ever did
um i met people from all over the world
uh there were scholars i had this and i
was a street kid
on the low east side you know and um
you know i had no clue i i it took me a
couple of weeks to grasp
on to what was going on because they
moved really really quickly but when i
grasped
it i learned i learned so much man you
know you learn
you know about sociology you know
politics and you learn cultural stuff
and
and how all systems work and how
we can create a together community and
look out for everybody and things like
that
so academically like when you're
back at your high school were you super
into your classes there or were you just
kind of like
this place is wack the administration is
wack they won't stop suspending me i'm
gonna learn
my [ __ ] elsewhere well i i taught myself
a lot
and so the system i didn't i didn't
really care for the system
i knew that if you got a 66 it was a
passing grade
you know 66 so you know it was like um
it was like you know i was i was an
average student because
it didn't mean anything to me because i
knew my intelligence
was outside of that because i
go ahead oh i was just gonna say well
yeah it must be hard
to also take all that stuff seriously
when you're opening your history
textbook and you're like
okay there's one paragraph about puerto
rico and it's wrong
right well that but but you know i had
the motivation to
get my own books you know i
i would go to the bookstore and i would
look around and
i would look up i would look in the
cheap rack
and anything that i could find poetry
history
art photography those were the books
that i would buy
you know and i would just look through
them
and and see all the things that i could
learn but also
um i had great mentors growing up
and so you know having these discussions
were amazing
and were most of your mentors it seemed
like they were coming outside of your
school
not really like teachers i have i
hey look man i had a i had a dean mr
loser
he looked out for me i think he
understood me where i was coming from
i had a a true guidance counselor
mr patterson and mr sunshine and they
looked out for me
oh mr sunshine that's very sweet yeah
man god bless them
you know and um but i also have like
some of the main counselors for my
speeder you know mm-hmm
lydia gonzalez abraham cruz izzy colon
uh larry you know gloria
i still you know and and and um i'm
still in touch with a couple of them
to this day that's great and are you are
you still friends with
like some of the old crew of like your
peers
yeah that's my history that's my those
are my roots
you know i i uh i talk to them
on the regular still just check in with
them and see how everybody's doing
that's great yeah that's i mean it seems
like you
um you just were really like
involved in your actual community and
like
giving back to it whereas i a lot of
people i talk to a lot of teenagers are
like they can't wait to get out of their
community
but you were giving back so much well
but it was different times
yeah it was a different time like you
know
i mean now so much stuff is gentrified
that you don't really see a community
where you live
you pass a lot of people that you don't
know
you know back back in the day
back in the day you were living in the
trenches man you were living in
in abandonment you know and and and
you had that in common with all the
people that lived there
you know so so um survival skills
become huge what we're like um
like you and your boys are out it's a
summer day you're walking around what
are like the spots
that you would go to to like hang out or
how would you like pass your time
back in those days man like a friday
saturday night
would be a good time to go clubbing you
know there were a few clubs that we
would
that we would hit um you know
it was disco you know with disco dancing
and um you know we just go out we have a
good time have a couple of drinks
you know smoke a little weed you know
get our groove on the dancing on
and you know sometimes we're walking
back home at
four in the morning and we hit the kuchi
frito spot you know that was open all
night
you know what i mean go into the greasy
spoon
and get stuff and mess up our stomachs
and
just eat like the most messed up thing
you possibly can
and go home yeah i mean that's a
beautiful you know what
you know what i mean it didn't always
mess up my stomach but once in a while
but it was full how did the actual
transition from or i don't even know if
you would consider it a transition from
but how did you end up
becoming a professional actor
okay so what happened was
[Laughter]
so what happened was that um
i ended up becoming a social worker and
i worked at a place called henry street
settlement on the low east side
and i was working with young people
between 14 and 17 years old i mean
17 and 21 year olds and
one day a couple of kids didn't show up
to my program and i went into the street
looking for them
which is something i never did
and on that day i ran into my friend
that i had seen in a few years
miguel pineda who i wrote short accent
so miguel tells me yeah yeah i'm ready
for the tv show they're coming to new
york
they're going to be looking for people
he gave me a phone number
i went i auditioned i had no clue what i
was doing
i went home blew it off a week later i
get a second phone call that the
producers and the directors want to meet
me
i go in boom boom read for them with
miguel
blow it off the third week i got a phone
call saying my name is richard
i read i represent miguel pineda i'm his
asian
and uh i would like to represent you
because you just
booked a three-week gig on the season
premiere of miami vice
oh my god i had no clue
what i was doing all i wanted to get out
of it
was to make enough money so i can buy me
a used
car i can drive to the beach on the
weekends
and not have to take mass transit that's
all i
wanted uh did you get the car
yeah my friend told me the next day
[Laughter]
so so after after i did that job i went
back
you know i didn't understand
entertainment
you know yeah i was just about to ask
like did you have any understanding of
how
crazy that was no not a clue not a clue
so um i went back to work
do my nine to five because it was
something that i loved doing and
something that i was
very passionate about and um
and um i will get different little parts
here and there because it subsidized my
salary
mm-hmm as a social worker um but
again my passion was helping young
people to help themselves to get them
off the welfare roads and
you know so i started getting more roads
a little bigger road and stuff like that
um
i ended up getting married um i ended up
starting with family
and then i just kind of left being a
social worker because
it got very bureaucratic you get worked
out
and i took that leap of faith and i said
you know what let me see what happens
with this acting
yeah and here we are
and here and here you are on my podcast
i feel like this is actually a perfect
place for me to ask you the
last question that i always ask everyone
on the show
which is if you could talk to teen
louise today what would you tell him
if i could talk to who your teen self
today
oh if i could talk to my team self what
would i tell him today i said
okay buddy there's this thing called
apple okay save up a thousand dollars
all right no matter and you're gonna
take that thousand dollars
and then you're gonna do this thing
called the stock market and the apple
coming out at
10 cents kid buy a thousand dollars of
that
see me 20 years later and you buy your
own
item [ __ ] the car your friend's gonna
total it
buy apple stock buy apple baby
um i mean you know because like you know
you're not you're not geared to learn
those things especially
as a as a latino we're not here to like
we're geared to like okay put money in
the bank only to find out
that the bank takes your money and
invests your money and makes so much
money
but they're paying you point zero zero
zero
two percent mm-hmm you know exactly
you're not taught how to how to take a
hundred dollars and make three hundred
dollars
yeah there's and there's a reason that
that information is like
passed down generationally but doesn't
get to
like latinos or other marginalized
groups that's
intentional hello yeah man well it was
so amazing to have you on the show
i really enjoyed talking with you about
like
your life and the politics of it and
your work
um so yeah this is just an amazing
chance to get to chat and for everyone
listening at home
this has been the roast of your teenage
self podcast
you